what's happening there reject nation we
are shooting this
on john's birthday but this is probably
going up the day after jon's birthday
either way
show your love to john by hitting that
like button
he loves that it's all he has to do
right right feel it yeah i get a little
tingle every time that happens
so apparently e3 is going on right now
but i've seen a plethora of comments of
people being like why don't you guys
check out the battlefield 2042 trailer
i don't have an explanation no i mean
battlefield's a crazy ass game
so i'm sure it's worth checking out i
like violence
let's do it you excited john i am very
excited i want to see what the prequel
to blade runner 2049 looks
[Music]
[Music]
christopher nolan's battlefield
oh he's gonna be good
what
oh bad news
let's go damn
nice
awesome
war has changed
he got the battlefield the scope jesus
oh
yeah it's a collector
i am lost wow
this this is like dazzling in its own
carnagerous way
grappling hook it
whoo i like
glitches too
i love this it really puts you in the
perspective
oh jeez
oh god
yes
come on tom cruise
no no
perfect
oh based on real warfare
oh that's amazing
oh
wow
someone's controlling harp
it's a rolling main character
damn yeah this could be a drawer butler
movie
no
let's use this
oh it's bad ass
badass
the most intense title card of all time
that's battlefield for you guys man oh
oh no the gameplay reveal is to oh the
day we're shooting
a good thing putting this up in the
morning yeah you're going to be doing
your birthday thing
coming back here
he came in today so he's going to chill
out tomorrow but damn
i was bowled over by that maybe i'll
wait i'll wait for john
i don't want to deprive you that way of
the passion
[Laughter]
i'm excited to see more of it though i
mean this is insane it really does feel
like a roland emerick movie but if you
took that perspective that like the
godzilla 2014 movie puts you in where
it's like you're just in the midst of
every intense militaristic operation and
like the way this was edited
the way they really threw you with
cutting into povs to create these like
really big reactive moments
like yeah this is good stuff and it's
gorgeous man battlefield is not a game
series like i play
a lot it's usually if i'm like hanging
out with a friend who has battlefield
yeah i mean this is battlefield it's a
battlefield game
yeah it gets more insane yeah yeah but
in that perfect
sort of like gritty sci-fi movie kind of
way yeah it's not too broad
like the tomorrow war sorry chris pratt
dude he was who i imagined watching this
like we got to be playing as chris yeah
but for being like this like
insane cinematic trailer hundred
thousand percent
i get why this trailer is so big i can
only imagine what the gameplay trailer
is gonna be like because to me
battlefield
the way how with mortal kombat of when
you watch trailers for that you expect
it just to get progressively more
insane and violent what i associate with
mortal kombat
i kind of apply that to here before
military
shooter the craziest maneuver you can do
with weaponry
is pretty similar to real life weaponry
but in the most insane state oh yeah
it's like so
and it's incredibly heightened yeah yeah
one this is just like you know this is
society now it's just
two military units warring with each
other
stealing each other's dog tags wow that
was awesome they got to make a movie out
of this one yeah just an animated movie
just go animated you don't need to make
a real life
just do this don't let roland emmerich
make this for real
or something expand it man guys
subscribe to the real rejects if you
haven't done so already
hit that like button for john's birthday
do it like it
last but not least let's do up
john i hear you really want to shout out
robert gunderson robert gunderson my
dude can you hook us
up with like an atv or something so that
we can replicate this trailer because
that's what video games are for man
they're supposed to inspire you
to get out there and i mean you just
yeah i mean the last time
i heard about a big update in your life
you shifted jobs you know you were
working on selling people cars you
remind me of free guys so this would be
the perfect opportunity
for you to jump in you know break out of
the mundane
you know get some cars and weapons and
just go hog
wild in in in the real world though and
just see how that pans out for you and
if it doesn't work i mean hey
at least you got out there and you took
your swing yeah and who could blame you
for that
no one no one no one can no one so come
over here and let's play some
some battlefields i hope you like video
[Music]
games
you